Hopes are high that the 13th installment of
the popular slasher franchise will make it
to the big screen sooner rather than later.
Until then, let's take a look back at all
the Jason Voorhees stories that never came
to life.
These are the Friday the 13th projects you'll
never get to see.
A crossover between A Nightmare on Elm Street
and Friday the 13th was first pitched in 1987.
And while it took 16 years for Freddy vs.
Jason to become a reality, loads of scripts
were written to support a slew of potential
mashup ideas.
According to Bloody Disgusting, a potential
script called Nightmare 13: Freddy Meets Jason
wrapped Jason Voorhees' origin story right
into Freddy's, suggesting Freddy Krueger was
the Camp Crystal Lake counselor who drowned
Jason Voorhees.
This angle gave Jason an intriguing motive
for becoming a killer and wanting to battle
Freddy.
The script was reportedly rewritten to include
a battle scene between Freddy and Jason that
took place in a boxing ring in hell.
An actor would portray Ted Bundy as the ring
announcer.
And guess who was supposed to sit right in
the front row?
Adolf Hitler.
Perhaps it's for the best that we never got
to see this one.
New Line Cinema pitched their own Freddy vs.
Jason idea in 1997, and the O.J. Simpson trial
inspired their version of the story.
According to Flickering Myth, the script took
a similar approach to Wes Craven's New Nightmare,
adding a meta layer that explored Jason going
on trial for his many murders.
"Are you trying to justify to me the fact
that you're an idiot?"
Freddy Krueger eventually enters the action
and attempts to use Jason to get out of dreamland
and into the real world.
Well, it certainly would've been interesting
to watch Jason take the stand, much like Freddy
did in an episode of Freddy's Nightmares called
"No More Mr. Nice Guy," directed by Tobe Hooper.
"Come on!
I'd rather burn up than fade away!
I'll be back…
I'm free… free!"
After the success of Platinum Dunes' Friday
the 13th reboot in 2009, Paramount and Warner
Brothers started working on a follow-up with
the studio.
"Uh, are you looking for this?
'Cuz it, uh, it completes your outfit."
Bloody Disgusting reports a sequel called
Friday the 13th: Camp Blood was written in
2010 by Damian Shannon and Mark Swift, the
same guys who wrote the Freddy vs. Jason script.
According to multiple rumors, Derek Mears
was going to play Jason again, the film would
be shot in 3D, and the plan was to release
the film opposite Platinum Dunes' other genre
reboot: 2010's A Nightmare on Elm Street.
"I'm your boyfriend now."
Producer Brad Fuller ultimately announced
the cancellation of the project on Twitter
in 2010, writing:
"It's not my call: I would drop everything
and make it today if they wanted it."
Seven years later, a never-before-seen image
was revealed on Shannon and Swift's Twitter
feed: The title page of their never-filmed
script.
Looks like they were was planning to kill
off Jason once and for all.
Yeah, right.
"We weren't doing anything.
We were just messing— "
In 2013, Christopher Nolan's Interstellar
managed to reignite Friday the 13th hopes.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, Warner
Brothers gave its rights to the franchise
over to Paramount to have a stake in the science
fiction epic.
David Bruckner, the director of the "Amateur
Night" installment of the 2012 horror anthology
film VHS, was brought on to direct.
Nick Antosca, the screenwriter behind the
Hannibal film adaptation, signed on to write
the script.
What they came up with sounds like it would
have been a lot of fun.
It would take place in the '80s.
Jason's mom would have a role in the film,
and it would allegedly focus on Jason's supernatural
mythology.
Bruckner told Fangoria he wanted to make a
cross between slasher horror and slacker comedy:
"My take on it was that I wanted to do Dazed
and Confused meets Jason Voorhees, a genuine
last-day-of-school coming-of-age story."
Unfortunately, due to the poor box office
returns of the horror sequel Rings, Paramount
wound up slashing Friday the 13th right off
its lineup.
Would the story of Jason Voorhees work on
television?
The CW's Mark Pedowitz clearly thought the
answer was "yes."
In 2015, the network announced they had a
Friday the 13th TV series in the works.
Series creator Steven Long Mitchell described
the tone as, quote, "a cross between the first
season of True Detective and Twin Peaks on
acid."
That's an odd analogy, considering those shows
seem like they're on acid already.
According to Mitchell, the story would have
followed a police detective looking for his
lost brother in Crystal Lake.
The central mystery would revolve around whether
Jason was killing again or a copycat was on
the loose.
Sadly, the CW ended up passing on the series.
Pedowitz told Collider:
"We didn't believe it was a sustainable script
or a sustainable series.
It was a very good pilot, but not a sustainable
series."